we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p every few months
the san antonio troll comes out of the
woodwork
and this guy has been calling in for
years at this point
and what i love about this caller is
almost
every time he calls in he criticizes me
for something i haven't even talked
about and he's doing that again today
and what's really funny is
some of what he mentions i haven't
talked about
some of what he mentions i haven't even
heard about i don't know what he's
talking about here listen to this
pacman i think i've solved it i have
solved
why why you don lemon
uh joy behar uh bill maher
[Music]
vosh all the you know the same topic you
all have the same kind of
exact same politics okay i figured out
why it's one
by the way bill maher and vosh do not
have the same politics okay let's
continue who's
why for one none of y'all are talking
about why the 15
minimum wage is getting the they're
kicking the can to 2025
none of y'all spoke about that but
instead we're worried about who's
starring in the next
disney plus film i i've never i don't
i didn't even know there was a
controversy about the next disney plus
film
and that's superman gonna be black is
this i didn't even hear about
anything about superman being black
these are stories i haven't even heard
of nevermind talked about why is he
calling me
he should be calling people who talked
about it spikey colin kaepernick and
nike shoes
i figured out why we're more worried
about that than actual workers getting a
fair wage
because you're rich are you done with
the other all meal i got money
who cares if workers get more wages but
disney that's what y'all like disney
posted netflix so it's important
that they have disney plus i i don't
know what he's talking about you know
non-white actors and stuff like hey i
get it
but man dude we some of us really need
money man where's that covered relief
your boy biden promise
i i and it's funny he he's acting like
i'm talking about disney plus and not
coveted relief
who who on the left uh has been more
critical
of the delay on this than i have i mean
i'm lots of people are being critical
but we
we've been following the delays on
kovatov from day one we've been
covering the the watering down of
coveted relief from day one i think this
guy's got the wrong show nowhere in
sight
they keep pushing it delaying it and
this and that
i'm with you well it's 20 20 funny 2025
and it's a thousand dollars now and i
see it's the same thing and it's
you you guys keep making excuses but
instead on your
i've made no excuses channel the most
important thing in the world
is disney plus netflix yeah so that's
the san antonio troll
and you know i wish he he does things a
lot of people don't do
he's audible in the voicemails a lot of
people call calling you can't hear what
they're saying
he gets right to the point a lot of
people call in they go three minutes and
before they even get to the point the
voicemail system
the san antonio troll could be a good
caller but
he's criticizing me for things that i've
never even talked about and sometimes
that i don't even know about it's sad
it's a sad state of affairs we've got a
great bonus show for you today mike
pence finally breaks his silence
and he's criticizing the 2020 election
we will talk about why some u.s catholic
bishops are discouraging
parishioners from getting the johnson
and johnson vaccine
we will also talk about parlor suing
amazon
again and what's going on with that all
of those stories
and more on today's bonus show
get instant access by signing up at
joinpakman.com
the coupon code remains available the
coupon code is
better21 all one word could be lowercase
you could spell it all caps you could
alternate it's not
case sensitive but it is all one word
better21 at joinpakman.com
i'll see you on today's bonus show